300 ال فلسطيني هم سكان رفح اصبحوا مليون
و700 الف بعد النزوح الاخير 300 ال منهم
نصبوا خياما بمحاذاه الشريط الحدودي مع
مصر والحدود مغلقه من الجانب المصري لمنع
تهجير الشعب الفلسطيني من قطاع غزه الى
سيناء وقد عززت الحكومه المصريه تامين تلك
الحدود نشر صحفي فلسطيني بقطاع غزه اسمه
احمد المدهون فيديو من امام السياج الفاصل
مع مصر يظهر عمالا مصريين يشيدون سورا
اسمنتيه على الحدود مع القطاع من زاويه
اخرى عبر تصوير بالسياره يظهر لك حجم
البناء المكتمل لهذا السور لكن لم يظهر
المدى الكامل السوري الاسمنتي على طول
الشريط
الفاصل يبدو من الفيديو ان العمال
المصريين كانوا يبنون هذا السور ليس
بالجديد انما هناك سور
قديم ولكن هناك زياده في ارتفاعه يعني
عملهم كان فقط لزياده ارتفاع السور وليس
لبناء سور جديد والتعليقات كثيره على هذا
الفيديو بناء سور اسمنتي بين مصر وغزه
احمد يقول لك في تغريدته من حق مصر تامين
حدودها والحفاظ على امنها القومي عزت يقول
المعلن اكمال تطويق رفح وتاكد من عدم وجود
انفاق مع مصر غير المعلن ا حلب الممر
منطقه حرب ومتوقع قذائف طائشه تستهدف سور
الحدود المصري امير الا
يستحق انين طفل جائع واحد في غزه ان يهدم
لاجله الف سور ويزال لاجله ال سياج
بالنسبه لتامر لقمان قال ماذا لو اسرائيل
ضربت السور الحدودي حول معبر رفح زي ما
بتضرب قرب البوابه وعلى الطرق المؤديه لها
في غزه ماذا ستفعل مصر مع الفارين من جحيم
القصف في غزه
تاتي هذه التحركات المصريه في ظل حديث عن
تحرك عسكري اسرائيلي نحو محور فيلادلفيا
لكن رويترز نقلت عن مصادر رسميه اسرائيليه
ان الجيش الاسرائيلي سينسق مع مصر بشان اي
عمليه تمشيط في
رفح وسيبحث عن سبل لاجلاء النازحين نحو
الشمال وليس الى السيناء